مشروع الزواج يسجل تراجعا في اغلب الدول
العربيه منذ سنوات فبحسب مركز الخليج
العربي للدراسات والبحوث اللبنانيات حفظنا
على المرتبه الاولى في ترتيب اكثر
العربيات تاخرا في سن الزواج وذلك بنسبه
85%
التونسيات في المرتبه الثانيه بارتفاع
نسبه التاخر في سن الزواج الى نحو 81%
وبنسبه القدرت بين 70 الى 85% حلت عراقيات
في المرتبه الثالثه في نسبه تقديريه بنحمل
70 الى 75% تاتي الاماراتيات في المرتبه
الرابعه اما المرتبه الخامسه فكانت نصيب
السوريات بنسبه 70% وحاله المغرب العربيات
في المرتبه السادسه بالنسبه
ارتفاع بنحو 20% خلال العقل البادي
المرتبه السابعه من نصيب الاردنيات بنسبه
55% مع نسبه ارتفاع منهم 10% خلال العقل
الماضي ايضا اما جزائريات فئتين في
المرتبه الثامنه بنسبه واحد 51% والمرتبه
التاسعه كانت نصيب المصريات في نسبته
كانوا 40%
السعوديات شاهدنا انخفاض في ترتيبهم الى
10% مقارنه بتقديرات 2013